president biden declaring america first
is dead
the president causing controversy in two
key areas today
the vaccine and foreign policy while
meeting with world leaders biden jumped
on
board the vaccine equality bandwagon
and then later today he promised to
distribute the shot more
fairly to the world he's also dishing
out four billion dollars to do it
keep in mind we've only fully vaccinated
12 percent of the american people
it's not enough that we find cures for
americans
there needs to be cures that the world
is able to take part of because you
can't build a wall
or fence high enough to keep a pandemic
out
as for america first when it comes to
foreign policy
biden boasting that it's a thing of the
past
america is back i speak to you today as
president of the united states
at the very start of my administration
and i'm sending a clear message to the
world
america is back the transatlantic
alliance is back
and we are not looking backward we are
looking forward together
i know i know the past few years have
strained and tested
our transatlantic relationship but the
united states is determined
determined to re-engage with europe to
consult with you
to earn back our position of trusted
leadership
all right juan please educate me here
because
under the trump administration we've
strengthened nato cut a mideast peace
deal
cut trade deals with mexico and canada
and south korea and china
i just don't see exactly where we went
it alone
and even if we did so what
well i you know i mean we can have a
debate about isolationism
uh versus the u.s engaging the world
uh as a global leader but i don't think
there's any question jesse over the last
four years under president trump
his approach to nato for example was
very
critical not only about funding and the
like but
making it clear that the u.s you know
was sufficiently
strong militarily and economically to
make their own decisions and not
engage in alliance alliances that have
been
standard since world war ii and i think
that what you're hearing from joe biden
today is
he's engaging that same post-world war
ii attitude an attitude that was engaged
in by
you know franklin delano roosevelt to
ronald reagan to george w
george h w and george w bush to barack
obama
that says america is a light on a hill
and that we
are going to have something to say about
the way the world moves and
is the world is shaped going forward
because
you know it is hard in this era to talk
about
being alone it it's it's almost
impossible
and leading is expensive okay so
engagement
okay did you want to jump in there
jillian oh i was just saying you know if
you do want to lead it's going to cost
money in today's world that's the other
reality
it's going to be expensive um the thing
about
biden today is you may not agree with
his decision to join kovacs that's the
international vaccine alliance
you may not agree with his decision to
have america rejoin the nuclear deal
but these things happening at once are a
living breathing example of the biden
doctrine if you didn't see them coming
you've been living under a rock for the
last
12 years i mean he's been talking about
the you know wanting the u.s to join in
a deal with iran since before he was
even the vice president
however many 13 years ago now on the
campaign trail
a quick word on the iran nuclear deal
announcement that's come out of this
today gen sochi told reporters on air
force one
that one of the main reasons they want
to get the u.s back in is to have quote
visibility into what's happening on the
ground inside iran she said under trump
we had no idea what was going on when we
pulled out of that deal we lost our
ability to see inside the country
and protect ourselves from their nuclear
development fine but then in the next
breath
saki said under the current plan the
united states will not be talking to
iran directly
at all they will be doing all
communicating through europe
as a former foreign policy official my
question for the white house would then
be
how do you plan to have any visibility
if we're not actually talking with iran
at all how are we going to sit down and
get a deal with them
if we never sit down at a table with
them
greg gottfeld yes jesse how are you
i'm fine thank you how are you i'm great
i'm doing good it's friday
thinking about what i'm gonna eat i was
also thinking about a new slogan for uh
joe instead of america first it could be
america you're not all that or america
it's not it's not me it's you because in
a sense
joe biden is breaking up with the
american public
in favor of a hot new exotic
partner the world right the world it's
very alluring it's got an accent
it's international makes you feel
cosmopolitan when you get to fly all
over the place
but he said sorry america joe just
isn't that into you anymore and the
media
has to push this myth that somehow
trump's foreign policy
had taken america off the stage and that
was in shambles
but they have to push that narrative in
order to allow joe to succeed by
undoing what trump did so you don't hear
about north korea
which is always the most important thing
joe entered this picture
never being asked about north korea why
is that
because it's not a problem who made that
not a problem
a guy named trump remember that was the
biggest problem that was what obama told
trump coming in
the biggest problem north korea he said
that to him and then all of a sudden the
biggest problem goes away
then you have the a plethora a word i
love to use
of middle east peace plans you got the
trade deals you got mexico stepping up
on the immigration
you have something that i like to call
no new wars
uh you killed an iranian general who
killed a lot of people you killed a few
terrorists
i mean this is not he had a pretty
phenomenal foreign policy uh resume
and i think the media pretends it was
terrible because he was an outsider
who kicked the insider's ass trump
exposed
the exposed the john kerry's and the
hillary clintons of the world and all
these swampy cohorts
that they're incompetent charlatans i
mean even fareed zakaria
has admitted that trump did some good
things which means he did some
did more than a few good things as for
the vaccines
i would be very suspicious when i hear
phrases like vaccine nationalism
and it's implied that if you want to get
americans vaccine
vaccinated first or xenophobic and
that's a phrase that the media and
is pushing primarily the washington post
but the simple
the simple facts is in order to help
others you have to help
your family first a good neighbor uh you
have to tend to your home and your
property before you can help others the
guy with the great lawn
has the tools but he's got to do his
lawn first before he can help yours
the idea that somehow we should be doing
this with before we do us
that's not sound policy
and it will fly just i'm having could
you imagine the back
i'll tell you what i'll could you
imagine the backlash if the french start
getting shots and
and people in in philadelphia and
detroit haven't been shot yet
yeah well but you know but you know what
this speaks to
it speaks to the biden administration
policy
which is america last and that he would
get up and say forget about
everything that has happened in the past
forget about our telling you nato that
by the way
you have to pay your own way i'm tired
of taking you to dinner all the time
and i'm going to make sure that my
people are protected
that my people have jobs all of a sudden
that's a bad thing
but the amazing part of all of this is
that this vaccine equity movement
is crazy because it was donald trump who
did the warp speed and the vaccine
and the whole issue by the way with iran
i mean this is just obama all over again
and remember when we were negotiating
with them the tats and the
tans and the facility they hid from us
iranian-backed militia
attacked us in in iraq and erbil
i mean who were we kidding here this is
nothing more
than biden's uh obama apology
to the middle east when he went to egypt
and apologized for america
biden is doing the exact same thing in
his first 30 days apologizing to the
world for being america
and confirming america will be last
because i'm going to put everybody else
first and i'm giving you 4 billion
to make sure everybody's vaccinated
while people in america
are suffering i don't buy it never did
don't think it's american
but then i'm american
[Laughter]
i guess the only difference is it's a
virtual apology tour
it's all just over the satellite
hopefully that changes soon
coming